nice to see you all this morning with
his party membership restored jeremy
corbyn left for parliament today
thinking he was once again a labour mp
thank you very much for coming this
morning
thank you very much but facing a
backlash from the jewish community and
his own front bench
his successor decided he had no option
but to prevent that from happening
kirstama said mr corbyn had undermined
efforts to win
back the trust of the jewish community
and so for now at least
was not welcome back on labour's green
benches
i think kier has made um give the
clear decision today um a difficult
decision i'm no doubt
for him and i hope that you know we can
begin to move on from from this issue
now
but jeremy corbyn's allies have reacted
with fury
accusing kia stammer of vindictive and
vengeful action
unite union boss len mccluskey said the
continued persecution of jeremy corbyn
a politician who inspired millions by a
leadership capitulating to external
pressure
on party procedures risks destroying the
unity
and integrity of the party ian lavery
who served as party chairman during
corbyn's leadership
said the move risked delaying the
party's efforts to tackle anti-semitism
we want to banish anti-semitism in all
forms of racism fascism
bullying and intimidation from the fears
of the earth we all want that
and i think that was a missed
opportunity today just to draw line on
that
implement the recommendations and move
on
but many other labour mps back the move
and say the way the case was handled by
the party's governing body
left kierstarma no option but to act
this isn't a left
right issue this is about racism and
tackling racism that's it
and if anyone wants the labour party to
be a bit racist they don't belong in the
labour party
while some in the jewish community have
welcomed the decision others say
to do that to say to the jewish
community that's all you're getting
no justice no impartial process just
this gesture
it's giving us crumbs it's conning us
and it's trying to send us away
without justice and we won't have it
when he became leader kia stammer said
he would seek to unify his party
and rebuild trust with the jewish
community today
he put one of those goals ahead of the
other
tom rayner sky news westminster